Mit face sei die sollte das iphone denn eigentlich zum sichersten
mobiltelefonen weltweit werden ein hack sollte unmöglich sein doch genau der ist jetzt einer vietnamesischen firma für computer sicherheit gelungen wie sie das geschafft
Haben und ob der hack jetzt alle iphones ten unsicher macht jetzt in science fiction herzlich willkommen
Heute aus mainz das sollte eigentlich nicht passieren apples iphone galt zumindest bei seiner vorstellung als
besonders sicher der sensor für die gesichtserkennung ist extrem ausgeklügelt und projiziert per infrarot
30.000 messpunkte auf das gesicht zusätzlich kann eine aufmerksamkeits prüfung checken ob man auch wirklich die augen auf hat und auf das handy schaut also
Doppelt und dreifach gesichert und es ist so praktisch jetzt braucht man gar nichts mehr zu tun ein blick genügt und das iphone ist entsperrt
war
Richtig cool aber schon bei touch ein die wurden sicherheitslücken entdeckt wer an den fingerabdruck des richtigen fingers kamen konnte das gerät
entsperren selbst auf fotos festgehalten fingerabdrücke auf trinkgläsern reichten aus also nicht 100 prozent sicher aber
Face id sollte sicherer sein sollte also was haben die vietnamesen gemacht umfelds sei die zu überlisten
Erstmal das iphone war mit der maximalen sicherheitsstufe gesichert zusätzlich zur gesichtserkennung wurde auch die aufmerksamkeit
Geprüft eine prüfung die zum beispiel verhindert dass man jemand einfach umbringen um an die daten
Zu kommen mit dem gesicht eines toten kann das iphone ten eigentlich nicht entsperrt werden eigentlich dieses sicherheitsfeature
wurde von der sicherheitsfirma
Intensiv geprüft nach einigen versuchen gelang es ihnen das iphone zu entsperren obwohl ein auge zugedrückt war und auf dem anderen auge ein
foto des auges klebte die
aufmerksamkeits prüfung war also nicht ganz so aufmerksam wie apple es behauptet und dann kam der versuch mit der maske der
Firma gelang es eine maske herzustellen die in der lage war das iphone tatsächlich zu entsperren
allerdings und jetzt können sich alle wieder entspannt zurück lehnen
Es dauerte sehr lange bis sie die maske so angefertigt hatten dass sie auch funktionierte immer wieder entsperrten sie dafür das iphone mit dem
Gesicht der echten person und modifizierten die maske ein prozess der in der realität anders als bei einem fingerabdruck
Nicht funktionieren würde man bräuchte schließlich die mitarbeit
Des echten besitzers oder der besitzerin mehr ist sicher haben will kann das iphone übrigens auch
So konfigurieren dass es nach zehn versuchen alle daten löscht das ergebnis ist also tatsächlich lässt sich facetime
Austricksen dafür wäre aber die mitarbeit der person nötig die zugriff auf das iphone
War das ein komplett absurdes szenario ist face aldi damit die sicherste methode bisher, um ein handy schnell und einfach
zu sichern also entwarnung und ich muss auch sagen
Mir ist das einfach zu sicher wenn ich morgens mit einem aufwacht gesicht auf das handy schauer passiert
Nichts das gerät hat mich morgens noch
Nie erkannt vielleicht kann
er ja mal was dran ändern
Ja
Und jeden tag gibt es hier neues aus wissenschaft und technik wenn ihr kein video verpassen wollt dann wird mir hier
Einen abort augen und vergesst nicht den genau auf die glocke denn nur dann verpasst ja auch wirklich kein video hier geht es weiter
Dafür auf das video klicken kulturschock ibm bus apple und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt an